électrique et c'est le nouveau produit
vedette chez Electro Yanni on se trouve
pourtant dans un atelier de réparation
d'appareils électroniques mais les
clients se font rares l'offre doit se
diversifier et quand j'arrive à
7 8 qui m'attend qu'il y a présentement
[Musique]
qui viennent par semaine après pour les
appareils électroniques
selon un sondage publié par équitter en
octobre dernier - 2 Canadiens sur 5 a
choisi de faire réparer un appareil
brisé au cours des deux dernières années
c'est l'option du remplacement qui est
largement privilégié on sent vraiment
une volonté la population mais un peu
une impuissance aussi parce que
justement il y a beaucoup d'obstacles
qui
vont quand ils veulent réparer
des obstacles que les réparateurs
connaissent trop bien qu'on parle
d'électroménager des fois ils sont pas
faits pour être réparés ou pour le
réparer faut changer un morceau complet
plutôt que une simple pièce ce
morceau-là sera moins ça a été un prix
pour éviter qu'il fait en sorte que le
consommateur a plus avantage a changé
économiquement parlant ou de téléphone
intelligent comme le iPhone remplace un
écran il va te dire c'est pas des Apple
et à chaque fois que vous redémarrer le
téléphone les messages bien ça c'est
quand même des massages et des choses
pour dire aux clients venez juste
réparer chez nous et c'est nous qui
contrôle ça c'est donc pour le rendre la
vie un peu plus facile que le
gouvernement fédéral compte instauré un
droit à la réparation dès l'an prochain
pour nous c'est quand même très bonne
nouvelle aucun détail n'a encore été
annoncé mais la volonté ad de quoi
réjouir selon équitter le droit à la
réparation en gros c'est des garantir à
la population que c'est bien vont
pouvoir être réparer facilement donc ça
ça veut dire un prix qui soit
raisonnable dans des délais raisonnables
aussi il est temps que ça arrive pour
Daniel Bollé ça doit notamment passer
par des pièces de rechange disponibles
plus facilement mais aussi plus
longtemps un manufacturier décide du
nombre d'années pour lequel il va
fabriquer les pièces de rechange ça peut
varier de 5 à 20 ans par exemple donc
mais malheureusement quand nous vous et
moi quand on magazine ils vont pas nous
dire ok l'appareil a lui les pièces sont
disponible 7 ans l'appareil B les pièces
sont disponibles 12 ans en France où on
impose des gens un droit à la réparation
cette information doit obligatoirement
être divulguée aux clients et aussi mis
en place un fond réparation donc qui
vient rembourser un certain pourcentage
de la facture de réparation le
directement à la personne qui fait
réparer son bien le droit à la
réparation c'est donc un frein à la
surconsommation et son poids
environnemental pour un téléphone
intelligent c'est l'équivalent de 600
fois son poids en ressource naturelle
qui est nécessaire pour le produit pour
un électroménager ça peut aller de 15 à
100 fois son poids pensez-vous qu'un
jour vous allez faire que de la vente de
moto et plus de réparation
non je vais toujours contourner la
réparation mais pour eux ce serait aussi
un coup de pouce bienvenue pour lui
permettre de vivre de sa passion ici
Mathieu papillon Radio-Canada Montréal